hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
chapters six through nine in alkyn of
york's on virtues and vices deal with
what we could call some virtues that are
particularly central within a christian
moral framework
and they're
not unique to christianity of course we
can find some discussions
of some of these sorts of things in
pre-christian philosophy as well but
they become really consolidated in
christianity and particularly from monks
like alcuin
who are trying to think out what does
the christian life require and you
notice that he's going to
cite a number of scriptural passages
that reinforce these including the
beatitudes
which are absolutely central for
christian morality and why talk about
these four chapters together why not
include some of the earlier chapters or
the you know chapter that follows
chapter 10 humility well all four of
these chapters really have to do
with
some related issues right so
how should we deal with other people
particularly when those other people
are
you know wronging us or insulting us or
being difficult to get along with where
do the
limits lie should we just like give in
all the time and let people run
roughshod over us should we be forgiving
to everybody indiscriminately
uh should we try to be peacemakers all
the time well then don't we end up
cooperating with evil and injustice so
this is a real significant set of issues
and alkaline is providing some very
helpful
commentary and all of these are
understood not just as regulating we
could call it relations with neighbors
but relations with our neighbors
in relation to and also to some extent
modeled by
god
and or commanded by god and involving
how god is going to treat us so he
begins by talking about peace pox
and he says that this is a
very important uh precept he says the
savior returning to the father as if
as a special gift gave the precept of
peace saying i give my peace to you i
leave my peace to you in peace i send
you out in peace let me find you he
wanted to give these things which he
desired to find in all when returning
and so he's saying listen this is the
way christians should actually
behave
and you know this combines as he says
the concord the like having uh agreement
uh not being in conflict with each other
of siblings of those within the same
household and also charity of neighbors
now charity is another word for the kind
of love that is supposed to be displayed
towards neighbors so peace
is not just a negative condition of like
not you know fighting with anybody
instead it's it's something much more
positive and
substantive
he also says a whole bunch of things
about it and we should look at these he
says peace is the mother of love okay so
again another connection with love a
token of sanctity
right
the health of the people the glory of
priests the the joy of the country the
terror of the enemy whether visible or
invisible and he says peace is to be
kept it with all vigor this is something
that requires
work on our part one who remains in holy
peace remains with the holy ones of god
so he's belonging to a larger community
and now notice two things about this so
he he's going to say it's for the priest
to admonish the people in peace what
they ought to do it's for the people
here in humility what the priest
admonishes so peace does not mean
nobody tells anybody what to do or you
know
criticizes them but it's supposed to be
done
in peace right and the priests
themselves might need to be criticized
from time to time hey you're screwing up
right
um and also notice
something we we brought up a little bit
earlier
right it is um
you know not just the mother of love and
token of sanctity the joy of the country
the terror of the enemy why would the
enemy be afraid of peace and who is the
enemy here well the greatest of enemy
here is you know the force of evil the
devil but bad people
don't really like peace even though they
can talk about it uh or pretend that
they they like peace because it gets in
the way of what it is that they really
want to do and sometimes peace itself
really bothers them
and so you know he's going to tell us
peace doesn't mean just indiscriminately
accepting everything and everyone
he's going to say that peace is to be
kept with the good
and those keeping the precepts of god
following the you know the rules
developing the virtues not with the
iniquitous and there that's just a
transliteration of you know
the the latin word for that and the
wicked the skeleratus right the uh
that's another word that comes up a lot
that has a lot of resonance
it's also not to be
kept with
the vices
the vices are bad
character traits that people have
developed you know and he's going to
talk about the eight capital vices in
here and also envy as another one so
it's not like you're you know if
somebody's envious you say oh well you
know love you as you are everything's
a-okay you can still say that
enviousness of yours is not good it
doesn't conduce to peace and then he
goes on and you know people often say
you know hate the sin love the sinner
what alcuin actually says is since the
bad deeds the mala of impious people
should be had in hatred odium
not the people themselves even though
they are bad why because they are
creatures of god so you can have as much
peace as possible with bad people
but you can't ultimately have
all that you know you can't have the
same as you can with good people
moving on to mercy
misericordia this is a really
interesting one and this is part of the
beatitudes you know blessed are those
who are merciful mercy will be shown to
them another word for misericordia could
be compassion right
there is a need to be merciful to others
why as he says a sinner cannot expect
mercy from god
who who does not have mercy to those
sinning against himself right so if you
want to be
if you want god to show you mercy you
have to however hard it is show
mercy to other people it says if we
desire our souls to be cleansed of the
filth of sins we should not deny
mercy to those sinning against us why in
the day of retribution we're helped by
works of mercy to the deserved mercy of
god we can actually afford it for
alcohol deserve mercy to some degree by
how we behave
so he says we have to be
merciful to our debtors he will be able
to expect forgiveness who has learned to
forgive
others
and then he says you know look you've
got a
divine
example here
you know
be merciful just as your father in the
heavens is merciful he makes his son to
shine on the good and the bad and reigns
on the just and the unjust these are
coming from
the gospels and you know these are ways
of saying you know quit being such a
vindictive jerk right um look at what
god does he he you know if he wanted to
judge people according to what they
deserve
maybe none of us would actually
survive now it's interesting because he
also points something else out is
again like the piece is peace just this
unlimited namby pamby you know butter
won't melt in your mouth thing no
mercy can sometimes have to be combined
with
justice or discipline and he talks about
this in the case of the judge
without
one without the other
would not allow him to do well
if there were mercy alone
that gives security to sinning
to subjects of the judge so if you
actually have some authority
putting up with
allowing people to behave badly
especially if they're affecting others
is not really being
merciful in the right way you also have
to extend
you know discipline or judgment or stuff
like that but he says if only discipline
were always present then
the mind of the delinquent is turned
into desperation and the judge will not
merit mercy from god
the other thing that he says that's
really really interesting here about
misericordia
um we should be merciful towards ourself
he says a person ought to begin this
mercy from himself
in what way is he merciful to others who
is cruel to himself and he might say oh
well that sounds you know you got to
love yourself before you can love others
well yes that's quite true but what does
alchemin actually have in mind
being merciful to yourself does not mean
giving yourself a pass on everything
it means recognizing yourself as what
you are
so he says he is cruel to himself who
prepares
perpetual flames for himself by his sins
he is rightly merciful who starts for
himself and keeps himself
diligently so being hard on yourself in
the right ways is actually being
merciful towards yourself because you're
saying
i'm not going to let you get away with
doing things that are actually damaging
to yourself
the next one that he talks about and
this is in chapter 8 is we can translate
it as remission or forgiveness in
dulgentia
and um
there's a variety of language that's
used here this is very closely connected
with the previous chapter about
mercy and he says that you know if you
want to have your sins forgiven by god
you need to forgive other people if you
don't forgive other people then you're
not going to be
forgiven yourself and now notice what he
says here that is really
quite interesting
he tells us
god
judges us
from our judgment
so what does that mean there
judgment can be understood in terms of
like an act of judgment you know we look
at ourselves and we're like well i
shouldn't have done that that was a
jerky thing to say or i shouldn't have
given into that temptation over there i
shouldn't have wronged that person
we also have a faculty of judgment
god is according to alchemin judging us
through our own
selves
right now our our own selves can often
be
off base
in this but he says that
in a measure it's in our power
potestas you know nostras
in what way we're judged by god our
judge
now what does he mean there so he says
that if we judge
mercifully about those offending against
us god will judge mercifully about us
offending against him and this does this
now notice what he's saying there
there's judging going on right so don't
just abandon judgment and be like oh
everybody's okay everything's fine
no there's judgment going on and we need
to be merciful in the judgments that
we're making and then we can expect this
mercy in return and this involves us
forgiving
he says
no one returning evil for evil don't be
conquered by evil but conquer evil in
good and so
you know we should show clemency we
should show
uh mercy we should show forgiveness to
people and then finally we get to
patience and this kind of brings it all
to
a close this this section
he says that
patience is necessary in human life
just as we ought to suffer patiently
injuries brought on us by others it's
also necessary to suffer patiently the
tribulations which will
happen to us so there's two main things
injuries from others and tribulations
and what are tribulations okay so that's
kind of a fancy biblically sounding term
for crappy things that are happening
that you know are going to test us
trials and tribulations people often say
another word that he uses here is
temptations
should these things happen it doesn't
mean that all the good that we've done
goes away right it just means that we're
required to suffer and that's what
potsienta is we're required to keep on
going
without allowing ourselves to lapse into
bad behavior so he says
patience is a perfect perfect work
nobody who is rightly wise who does not
have
patience we go back to the first chapter
about wisdom right if you want to have
wisdom you have to be doing all of these
things here and that is part of what is
being revealed
through you know we could say this this
christian framework and it perhaps
exemplified in the monastic life now
anybody who knows anything about
monastic literature knows that you know
sometimes this doesn't always take and
happen but it's perhaps more than in the
the secular life and so he says that
true patience is to bravely notice that
courage and patience are involved there
enduring injuries in the face and in the
future not to seek revenge but forgive
from the heart he'll talk about
uh the ability of forgiving
and not seeking out the opportunity of
revenge so true patience is not being
passive aggressive and grumbling and
saying i'll get you you know down the
line or something like that it's
actually letting
things go so patience remission mercy
peace these are all
intimately interconnected
with each other right he says we can be
martyrs without sword or flames if we
truly preserve patience and mind with
our neighbors this is actually quite
striking we can be martyrs martyrs are
those who die
for the truth of of christianity
witnessing to it martyr means witness
right
and we don't have to die we can just put
up with everybody's bs
that we're called upon and he says it's
more praiseworthy to avoid injury by
being silent than to overcome by
responding so this also you know goes
against the sort of passive aggressive
oh i'll just be patient with you
expressing that to another person just
shut up and deal with it right and and
you know do what you're supposed to do
so these four
virtues these four chapters that are
discussing them very very important in
the christian life as sketched out by
alkaline in on virtues and vices and you
notice the the connections of these with
each other
you